Transcriptor: Araceli Ponce
Revisor: Anna Sobota
Buenos días.
El rompecabezas de la motivación.
Como bien dice su nombre
hay que ir uniendo poco a poco las piezas
de este gran puzle que lo componen
para llegar a comprender
lo que supone esta palabra,
tan poderosa, de la motivación.
Mirad, os lo cuento
de primera mano.
Hay días en los que me levanto, y sé que
puedo llegar a ser una exagerada,
pero hay días, en los que me levanto
sin fuerzas de vivir, sin ganas.
Pero es que también hay otros días
en los cuales me levanto
como si la vida me sonriera.
Vivimos en una sociedad
en la cual se está normalizando más
el hecho de no tener
ningún tipo de motivación;
de esos adultos, y no tan adultos,
tirados en el sofá.
Llamémoslo y acreditémoslo
a este nuevo deporte: sofing.
Y sí.
Hay millones de personas que
no tienen una motivación, o eso dicen,
pero lo cierto es que no han hecho
ni el amago de intentar buscarlo.
Pleno siglo XXI: vivimos y queremos seguir
viviendo en esa rutina mediocre, monótona,
en la cual es lunes y,
en un abrir y cerrar de ojos,
queremos que sea viernes
para poder disfrutar del fin de semana.
Pero, ¿por qué?
Por las siguientes palabras:
por falta de motivación
personal y laboral.
Cuando hablo de motivación
no me queda otra que hablar de actitud.
Os voy a contar una anécdota de las mías:
Hace un par de meses
en pleno primero de Bachillerato
con grandes expectativas de la vida,
con ganas de comerme el mundo;
bueno, eso ya me entendéis;
me faltó algo.
En su momento no lo supe,
pero ahora sí.
Estuve un par de semanas
hablándoles mal a mis padres,
faltándoles el respeto verbalmente
y era por una simple razón:
por no querer ser feliz.
Sí, así es.
Porque es de valientes querer ser feliz.
Porque la vía rápida y fácil es
ahogarte en tu propio vaso
y no querer ver más allá.
Pero, a lo que deberíamos de
congratular más
es a esa capacidad de
luchar contracorriente por ser felices.
Mis padres, evidentemente,
pusieron freno a esto
e hicieron lo siguiente:
me pusieron un vídeo de Víctor Küppers,
el maestro de los maestros.
Al ver este vídeo entendí
que todo depende de mí.
Que tú mismo eres el pintor de tu vida
y que ya tú decides si quieres que tu vida
sea de color rosa o de negro.
Es necesario saber que
tú mismo, y solo tú,
eres quien lleva las riendas de tu vida.
Para tener el éxito
en cualquiera de sus formas
debes de tener primeramente ese éxito
personal, porque esta vida es muy dura.
Hay gente que te la encuentras
a las 8 de la mañana
deambulando por la calle casi a rastras,
llevando en la espalda una mochila pesada
que les impide subir la mirada.
Pero es que luego, está esa misma gente,
a la misma hora,
que lleva una sonrisa de oreja a oreja.
Tampoco digo que tengamos
que ser aquí un arcoíris andante.
No, ni muchísimo menos.
Pero tampoco deberíamos de llegar
al punto de parecer un alma en pena.
Debemos normalizar que hay días
en los que nos apetece este verbo
de llorar, llorar y nada más.
Por lo tanto, repito,
debemos de tener este factor
de la actitud para tener la motivación.
Evidentemente, hay otros mil factores que
componen este rompecabezas.
Nos permiten escalar esta gran escalera
para llegar a lo más alto.
Si nos paramos a pensar, absolutamente
todo tiene que ver con la motivación,
desde lo más mínimo hasta lo más evidente.
Ya que estoy hablando de la motivación,
de esta palabra tan poderosa
y de todo lo que lo engloba,
no me queda otra que hablar de aspiración.
Para mi, aspiración es sinónimo
de motivación.
Sí, una persona poco ambiciosa
es una persona que no aspira
a crecer como persona.
¿Para qué estamos viviendo
si no queremos crecer personalmente,
si no nos queremos superar?
Voy a hacer una comparación, un tanto
loca, pero la llegareis a comprender.
Nos considero a los seres humanos
similares a las plantas.
Por ejemplo, mi abuela, una amante de su
casa, muy casera, tiene muchas plantas.
¿Sabéis qué hace?
Habla con ellas.
Les muestra su afecto
y su cariño en palabras.
Y si supierais lo ilusionada
que me llamaba el otro día:
“Paula, Paula, ¿te acuerdas de la flor
que estaba a dos de morir?
Está como nueva.”
¿Dónde está la magia ahí?
La magia está en ese cariño
y en esa dedicación constante
que hacen que
el imposible sea posible.
Y, volviendo a esta comparación
de los seres humanos con las plantas,
habéis escuchado que dicen de ellas:
Si no las riegas lo suficiente, no se
pueden cultivar y se acaban muriendo.
Es ciclo que todos conocemos.
Pues, les ocurre exactamente
lo mismo a los seres humanos,
si lo contextualizamos.
¿Qué les ocurre?
Se mueren por dentro.
No hay nada peor que eso.
Personas vacías son personas tristes
y os puedo asegurar que este sentimiento
no es compatible con el de la motivación.
Porque el sentimiento de la motivación
es esas ganas de comerte el mundo,
de tener ganas de avanzar
y de querer superarte,
de tener constantemente en la cabeza
esta frase, que todos
conocemos, de Mr. Wonderful:
“Quien no arriesga, no gana”.
Pero, por desgracia,
la falta de motivación
es estado popular en este país.
Os voy a comentar algo
que yo vivo día tras día:
muchos de mis amigos
se están dejando Bachillerato
porque lo ven cuesta arriba
y tienen una falta
de motivación inmensa.
Yo digo que están echando
de su vida a perder.
A mí, me pueden llamar exagerada,
pero es que así es.
Todo es por no tener
unos objetivos claros y fijos.
Porque sin los objetivos
no tenemos esta dirección, esta guía.
Realmente nuestra vida ya no tiene
sentido, ya no cobra sentido.
Por lo tanto, escuchadme, apuntad:
necesitamos en esta vida unos objetivos
para no ir como pollos sin cabeza,
sin realmente saber lo que queremos hacer.
No es cierto que “todos los caminos
llevan a Roma”
o que todos los caminos
llevan a la motivación.
Necesitamos unos objetivos
para poder tener unas aspiraciones.
Unas aspiraciones tienen
unas motivaciones.
Ya me quedo sin tiempo
así que seré muy breve, lo prometo.
Tengo varias preguntas
que hacerles a todos ustedes.
¿Cuántos de ustedes os habéis sentido en
algún punto de vuestra vida atrapados
en esa monotonía de vida?
(Participantes levantan las manos)
Vale.
¿Cuántos de ustedes habéis tenido
una falta de motivación inmensa
un lunes por la mañana para
ir a trabajar y no habéis querido?
(Participantes levantan las manos)
Evidentemente, puedo seguir
pero es suficiente.
Realmente lo que quiero transmitir
con esta charla es la importancia
y el mensaje que conlleva
la palabra de la motivación.
Es la suma de actitudes y aptitudes.
Tiene dos partes.
La primera parte, la he explicado
durante esta charla.
Luego están las aptitudes
que es lo que consigo desarrollar
gracias al conocimiento
que he obtenido por la motivación.
Está en vuestra mano
si queréis que forme parte
de vuestra vida
o si quizás queréis seguir con esa vida
que, a veces, no tiene sentido,
es repetitiva y monótona.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)